the united states has marked another
somber milestone in its fight against
the coronavirus pandemic
on monday the number of covet 19 related
deaths in the country surpassed 500 000
that translates into 148 dead per 100
000
infections let's compare that to some
other countries it's slightly behind the
united kingdom which has one of the
world's
highest death rates at 177
per 100 thousand germany has a
relatively low death toll
with only 78 per 100 thousand that's
half the us figure u.s president joe
biden led americans in observing a
moment of silence to honor
the nation's half million coronavirus
victims
today we mark a truly grim
heartbreaking milestone
500 071
dead that's more americans
who have died in one year in this
pandemic
than in world war one world war
ii and the vietnam war combined
that's more lives lost to this virus
than any other nation
on earth but as we acknowledge the scale
of this
mass death in america
we remember each person in the life they
lived
joe biden speaking there now we're
joined from washington by dw
correspondent stefan siemens
stefan in that speech joe biden said he
wants to reduce the bipartisanship
surrounding the pandemic is it too late
for that
no it's not well 500 000 dead americans
are definitely a reason to
leave bipartisan and political bickering
behind
but that was more aimed towards people
who
are affected by the pandemic who are
still alive
their economical votes their their
hardship when it comes to
paying rent uh getting enough food for
their kids uh and so on so
that was clearly uh aimed at what is
going on right now in washington that
the white house and democrats are trying
to
bring through the 1.9 trillion dollar
eight package uh joe biden wants to push
through and
with that fourteen hundred dollars for
eligible americans
and of course there is as pointed out uh
political bickering republicans are
against this and want to reduce the sums
and what is paid to people so that was
geared towards that but
however absolutely right the president
said said it it's it's a horrible number
500
000 dead americans is not not something
the u.s can be proud of
and yet the us is also one of the
leading countries in terms of
vaccinations around 13 percent of the
whole population have received
their first shot how is that changing
things on the ground you think
yeah that's good news and the
administration as well as the state
governments are pushing the pedal there
and there is hope for more even
faster broader vaccination programs to
be implemented here in the united states
um teachers bringing kids back to school
and teachers that teachers getting
vaccinated days
going to be a big push in that direction
too however
the problem is you see even if
the society here and and and towns
cities and
places open up a little bit more now get
a little bit more lacks in their
in their restrictions of people how they
gather where they eat is that where
restaurants open and so on
uh it's not broad enough and it's not
fast enough it could be broader and
faster and
don't forget there are predictions out
there uh who say that
up to 150 more 150 000 more americans
could die by summer
so that is not with all the vaccination
that is good
everybody's pushing the pedal here uh to
give more vaccinations to the people but
still 150 000 people could die
until summer still with all this going
on
stefan the us is in the top ten of
countries with the highest death toll
per capita why have so many americans
died in one of the world's richest
countries briefly if you can
well because uh the uh at least that's
what many experts say trump
administration the foreign
administration under uh
under donald trump has made significant
mistakes in the us was
really really really really late to
react could have been
done more i brought you something here
you see this was headline washington
post
in may last may last year okay hundred
thousand that was the first shocker
um the after that
the administration is stands accused of
not really grasping the
gravity the magnitude of the crisis here
and not doing fast enough
enough things fast enough to stop the
virus and to spread
and that's the reason why uh it went so
bad here in america america could have
done better everybody is
at the same opinion of that stefan zimas
in washington thank you stefan
you